Alors évidemment, Bonjour à tous !
il est 6h30 du matin,  vous n'êtes pas très bien réveillés et vous êtes dans le décor de Pierre Croce
vous vous faites réveiller par "évidement bonjour à tous"
c'est là que vous vous dites " j'me suis planté"
"c'est sûr j'me suis planté"
pas forcément, parce que au mois de Mars dernier
Pierre m'avait invité pour faire une vidéo ensemble,
et ça m'avait fait passer le cap des 10 000 personnes qui suivaient mes vidéos
et en cette fin d'année, nous renouvelons l’expérience, et ça c'est vraiment cool
alors, on l'a fait sur sa chaine, c'est déjà sortie, je vous mets le lien dans la description
et sans vouloir trop vous teaser, c'est la première fois, que sur une vidéo, je me foire
( INTRO )
Pierre : C'est bon, bon bah moi je suis prêt à commencer cette euh... vidéo
Fabien : Alors je vais juste leur expliquer, parce que autant, toi, tu sais à peu près
Fabien : Je vais demander, à Pierre Croce, quelque chose de très particulier
Fabien : Je vais garder les rush de ce "quelque chose de particulier" mais vous n'aller pas le voir, je vais couper
parce que, en faite, je truque mes vidéos comme ça, en faisant des montages (Ironie)
Pierre : Je sais, je sais, dans toutes les vidéos y'a des...
Fabien : sauf que exceptionnellement, je mettrais le passage coupé à la fin de cette vidéo là
Fabien : et vous saurez ce qu'il s'est passé à ce moment là
Pierre: j'ai rien compris, eux ils ont compris ?
Fabien : c'est Pierre proche (on dirait une blague)
Pierre : je peux tenir un peu tes abonnés ?
Fabien :(Tout bas) Par contre faut,faut... oui bien sûr
Fabien : ah oui, toi tu les tiens à pleine main
Pierre : ah ouai, bah écoute, des abonnés ça se tient bien hein
Pierre : il y en a beaucoup en plus, il commence à y en avoir beaucoup
Pierre : ils sont 165 000 là, non ?
Pierre : attend je compte vite...non, hey bientôt 170 000, ça va vite là
Fabien : ils sont pas très réveillés à cet heure ci, tu vois moi j'ai plus l'habitude de les voir à 17h
Pierre : Il y en a deux, trois au moins, là. Je reconnais
Fabien : et Il y en a deux, trois qui partent, parce qu'ils t'ont reconnu (rigole tout les deux)
Fabien : donc ça c'est un fond vert, en faite, de base
Pierre : non, c'est un parquet (rigole)
Fabien : tu vois, comme quoi, je ne connaît pas encore les termes techniques (rigole)
Fabien : alors Pierre je vais essayer de trouver ton mot de passe twitter, mais comme c'est ton mot de passe
Fabien : je te demanderai confirmation, je vais pas.. je vais pas te mettre dans l'embarras quoi..
Fabien :  je vais l’écrire ou un truc comme ça, je ferai en sorte qu'ils ne le voient pas, pas longtemps
Fabien: pas longtemps             Pierre: bah ouai, qu'il n'y ai pas de capture d'écran possible..  Fabien: je ferais comme ça (geste flou de la main )
Pierre : je te fais confiance, écoute on se connaît depuis longtemps maintenant
Fabien : après peut-être que eux, ils sont très très bon sur ma chaîe pour te mentaliser et qu'ils vont trouver en même temps que moi
Pierre : ah oui tu leur a appris les techniques
Fabien : heyy mais bien sûr, depuis 326 vidéos maintenant donc euh...
Pierre : donc, si quelqu'un se connecte, n'allez pas voir les messages privés.. N'allez pas voir les messages ....
Fabien : Est-ce que tu peux, par sûreté, juste effacer ce que moi je t'ai envoyé c'est tout... les photos... (rigole)
Fabien : alors première question, je te pose une question là, je te demanderai une vrai réponse
Fabien : Est-ce que il y a un mélange de lettres et de chiffres ?
Pierre : il y a un mélange de lettres et de chiffres
Fabien : d'accord... Est-ce que c'est mélangé aléatoirement ou est-ce que ça veut dire quelque chose
Pierre : euh... C'est à dire ? ça veut dire quelque choses ? Nan c'est pas...
Fabien : Bah par exemple, XR2B3
Pierre : non, non non ça veut dire quelque chose
Fabien : On est plus sur du "bibifox21" quoi ?
Pierre : c'est ça ! Bravo, fin de la vidéo (rigole)
Fabien : c'est ça ? et bien merci...rigole)
Fabien : Ça commence donc par les lettres, vu comment je t'ai vu réfléchir
Fabien : ...et ça finit par les chiffres, c'est correct ?
Pierre : tu m'as vu réfléchir ? tu pourras m'envoyer une photo la prochaine fois ?(rigole)
Fabien : est-ce que tu pourrais penser à la première lettre, me regarder et dire stop mais dans ta tête surtout pas pour de vrai
(rigole) ok ça c'est bien compris comme consigne ?
Tu dis stop dans ta tête au moment où je dis la première lettre de ton mot de passe, d'accord ?
A
B
C
D
E, F
G, H
I
J, K
L, M, N, O
P, Q
R, S, T
U, V, W, X, Y, Z
Ok, je pense que j'ai passé la lettre
Est-ce que ça s'est correct comme première lettre ?
Pierre : non
Fabien : c'est pas correct ?
Fabien : J'ai une bonne série de vidéos avec Pierre Croce moi je peux te dire que j'ai bien fait de venir
Pierre : Tu rates tout ce que tu entreprends avec moi
Mais peut-être que je sais pas bien faire stop dans ma tête non ?
Fabien : c'est ça. Bon, dis moi la première lettre
Pierre : C
Fabien : C ?
Pierre : ça ressemble à un G
Fabien : Ok. Mais en vrai c'est pas placé au même endroit. J'ai galéré sur la première lettre bon beh voilà mais au moins tout le monde sait que c'est un C
Pierre : Ah, tu vas mettre quand je te l'ai dit ?
Fabien : Bah ouais
Pierre : bah moi je suis pas aussi honnête
Fabien : Ouais c'est vrai
Pierre : quand je fais des tours de mentalismes
(rire)
Fabien : Je vais essayer de trouver le nombre de syllabes
Tu me regardes dans les yeux
Pierre : Ouais
Fabien : Là tu comptes tes syllabes dans ta tête
Si y en a 0
4 Op là ça s'est relevé à 2 donc on est à 2, c'est correct ?
Pierre : Tu m'as, tu m'as eu là
Fabien: hein?
Pierre:ah! ouais...
Ben, en fait, je crois qu'il faut que je te prenne à l'envers, si je peux me permettre
Et donc il y a des chiffres après
Donc ça peut être...
un chiffre entre 0 et 9
ça peut être un nombre, entre 10 et 100
Hop-là! Vous avez vu les yeux qui ont encore fait l'arc de cercle?
donc on est entre 10 et 100
Pierre: J'était en train de chercher une vanne, c'est pour ça.
Fabien: Ouais mais c'est pas grave, au moins, ça me donne des infos
Je vais commencer par le chiffre. Je sens que ça va mieux se passer
Pierre : attends, là, je vais essayer d'anticiper, quand même, tes petites astuces
Fabien: Ok, ça peut être un chiffre qui ne veut rien dire, pris complêtement au hasard,
Comme ça peut être quelque chose qui a du sens
comme 69, comme 51, comme... le 7, parce que c'est magique
mais ça c'est pas à deux chiffres
comme le 18 pour les pompiers comme le 15,
pour les ambulances, comme 13 qui porte bonheur
comme 98 pour la coupe du monde
de football... Et c'est quelque chose qui a du sens
et je l'ai déjà dit dans le tas
c'est correct
pierre:tu sais que c'est pareil
fabien:tu peux me confirmer que c'est bien le chiffre?
Je ne vais pas le faire voir, quand même.
C'est ça ou pas?
Pierre:Oui
Fabien:c'est 13?
Pierre : oui
Je te connais...
Fabien:le moment où je le dis, je peux le couper, et ils ne le saurons pas
on est amis ou pas?
Pierre : Bah, on est amis depis quoi? 4-5 ans, mantenant, qu'on se connait
Je te fais confiance là-dessus
Fabien: alors,il faut que je terminne de trouver le mot maintenant
en deux syllables
Pierre: syllabes
Fabien : en deux syllabes
tain.. je fais souvent la faute en plus
J'ai horreur qu'on me reprenne sur m chaine
*Rire*
Heu tu m'as dit que ça pouvait avoir du sens
Oh la vache, je vient de l'avoir
Pierre: non?
Fabien:Ben oui, je l'ai eu direct
mais je vous jure
je viens de l'avoir direct
je vous expliquerais tout à l'heure
non je ne pourrai pas vous l' expliquer
du coup
est-ce que ton mot de passe, c'est ça?
Pierre:Tu ne regarde pas les messages privés, hein tu me le promet?
Non mais par rapport aux photos et tout...
Fabien: j'aimerai telle ment vous faire voir, mais je ne peux pas
Tu sais comment je l'ai eu?
j'ai levé les yeux, j'ai vu le canard
Pierre : et alors, et attendez, petite variation quand même: Il y a un truc qui est incorrect
Fabien: ah bon? C'est pas canard 13?
euh, non, c'est pas ça. Déjà c'est pas ça, mais moi j'ai trouvé avec ce que j'ai marqué
Pierre: c'est qu'il y a une
minuscule
Fabien: Il y a une minuscule?
Pierre : ouais. tu veux pas inventer un petit tour de mentalisme pour donner la lettre sur laquelle il y a la minuscle?
Oh d'accord, alors tu pense à
la lettre sur laquelle il y a une minuscule
C, A, N,A,R,D. Ça a bougé sur le A, correct?
Pierre: quatrième A?
Fabien: ouais
Pierre: ouais
est-ce que je peux prendre 2 minutes pour effacer les deux-trois trucs,
au cas où il y a des gens qui se...
connecte par hasard sur mon compte
Fabien: Non, non, non, non
Pierre: D'accord
F: Tu sais pourquoi personne ne se connectera?
P: Pourquoi?
F: Parce qu'ils vont regarder
F: Donc là c'est le passage que je vais leur couper
je vais essayer de trouver le mot de passe de ton compte twitter mais
ça je vais leur annoncer, leur expliquer
je ne vais pas donner ton vrai mot de passe
évidemment
donc je vais te demander de changer de mot de passe dans ta tête
quel mot de passe tu pourrais mettre sur twitter là
tu changes ton mot de passe
physiquement où que dans ta tête
si tu veux
sauf que ça ils vont l'apprendre qu'à la fin
puisque durant la vidéo ils seront persuadés d'avoir ton vrai mot de passe
si jamais je le trouve
Pierre : les salauds !!!
voilà ça se sera mis donc à la fin en bonus
on revient au moment où ça reprend déjà
bah ouais c'était très bien attends
et même si le mot de passe a été inventé
oui
c'aurait quand même été très fort
alors ça c'est un coup de chance, comment ça s'est passé ?
oui complètement
parce que tu sais que en général la personne qui cherche va regarder toujours
exactement, j'avais fait une vidéo avec Lola Dubini
où elle devait elle inventer le nom d'une chanson
etc et en fait c'est souvent à la usual suspect
j'apelle ça
c'est-à-dire que si tu demandes à quelqu'un de créer quelque chose là pour faire un truc de mentalisme
eh bah comme dans usual suspect tu vas retrouver les éléments qui l'ont inspirés autour de lui
mais moi j'ai pas vu le film donc heuuuu....
bah à la fin le.... Pierre : nan nan j'ai pas vu
ouais ah c'est celui-là ?
parce que nous à la base on avait une question avec mes abonnés
ahhhhh ! j'écoute !
on voulait savoir comment se passait le régime
heuuu..... Ecoute heuuuu... Fabien : parce que on suit beaucoup
tes vidéos et on trouvait que ça en parlait plus
non je le cache totalement en fait
non attends la dernière vidéo que j'ai posté vendredi sur ma chaîne
l'angle de la caméra fait qu'on voit le ventre
et j'ai plein de commentaires dessus là
du coup je vais essayer de relancer quelque chose de fort
ouais
je vais peut-être aller chez Mcdo là et puis on va parler d'un partenariat avec eux
non un placement de produit sur toute l'année quoi
ils sont pas gentils sur cette chaîne hein ?
ils sont très gentils et très bienveillants et si jamais
y en a qui ont le malheur de pas encore connaître Pierre Croce
ou juste de connaître vite fait comme ça mais allez
déjà voir moi,
me gameller sur la chaîne de Pierre
j'ai fait un truc hyper rigolo et c'est la première fois que je rate
et bah ça ça se voit chez Pierre
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce en l'air, à vous abonner
à aller voir ce qu'on  a fait avec Pierre sur sa chaîne
et rendez-vous demain à 17h
Ciao !
Ciao ! Ciao !
Ciao ! Est-ce que tu crois qu'ils restent aussi longtemps quand on dit ciao ? J'espère pas
sinon ils n'ont pas de vie
ciao !
Ciao ! (Petit mot) N'hesitez pas à aller vous abonnez à Pierre Croce )